you know I found that many of your ideas
and presentations were very challenging
and dangerous to the limits that I felt
on my mind but I don't feel especially
terrified sitting across from you
talking with you I don't feel like
you're any danger to me no no I'm a nice
man that's part of the strategy
I'm the doorkeeper to deep dark water
that everybody explores on their own I
am NOT a guru I have no particular acts
of my own to grind or at least not with
great vigor I the point to be made here
is that psychedelics are not an ideology
or a position they are an experience and
an experience is something that we have
very intimately ourselves so it's not
something you can teach people or draw
to many general conclusions from it's an
experience but it's an experience that I
feel people should have and when I see a
political system or a set of cultural
values that are denying people this
experience
then I feel like some kind of human
rights abuse is taking place the tension
between the so-called straight culture
and psychedelic culture is attention
over values psychedelics challenge the
assumptions of any cultural or political
system and that makes them dangerous to
every cultural and political system so
there's anything a Marxist to
dictatorship and high-tech industrial
democracy or a theocracy they can all
get together on one thing which is
psychedelic drugs or a knife poised at
the heart of community values well this
is just simply nonsense and then all the
reasons brought forth are in a sense a
red herring
the psychedelics are among the safest
substance is known for human gesture
considering the depth of their impact on
human mental functioning the fact that
you pick yourself up six seven eight
hours later into the one about your
business with an expanded point of view
is quite remarkable people have a right
to get stoned they have a right to think
and explore their own minds this is as
intimate a part of their being
as their sexuality and in any culture
which mitigates that is clearly afraid
of a full and fair and open dialogue
about what reality is and what real
human values ought to be I think anybody
who takes a number of psychedelic trips
will eventually earn their oak leaves I
mean there you can spend difficult
evenings people who dismiss this as
recreational drugs or the hedonism err
escapism absolutely do not know what
they're talking about this can be very
challenging and difficult work that's
the ocean kayaking metaphor is more
appropriate don't think meditation and
yoga are the same enterprise as taking
psychedelics they are are often sold as
the same enterprise but in fact nobody
goes to the ashram with their means
knocking terror over what is about to
sweep over them on the other hand if
you're taking high doses of psilocybin
or DMT this would be a perfectly
reasonable response I'm interested in
everything I to my mind the psychedelic
agenda means visiting the most remote
parts of the world reading the most
forgotten obscure literature's and
having the most extreme experiences that
one can enjoy safely
you